this is Brad hotdogs good see buddy his
quotes keep keep getting taken out of
context that he's getting spun into
being like we're talking Nitro and
Peterson and he's getting spun into
being like transphobic and this and and
and misogynistic and and if you sit down
and actually talk to the guy and give it
some time like he's got educated
responses to what his ideas are and
whether you agree with them or not
he's not being evil he's actually got
education and research and all this
stuff people don't give a [ __ ] like you
hear people say things I don't care
about the context sick people think
you're [ __ ] you're an idiot yeah yeah
well yes pretty much everyone is an
idiot these days that just goes without
saying I was gonna say that no matter
what conversation I walk into that would
be my opening today
Peterson's probably the smartest guy
that I've ever interviewed uh-huh and
he's been doing this stuff for 30 40
years already
he controversial yeah but he is
incredibly well-educated on the stuff
he's talking about yeah and and this
idea about the that he doesn't like
trans people or gay people it has
nothing to do with that he didn't want
the government to pass a law to say you
would be in trouble if you use the wrong
pronouns but I've been with him he's
been to my house I lived there with my
husband the dude I married that's pretty
gay anyways he did he did it privately
which you respect it's like well yeah
you know bottle of Purell everywhere he
went yeah the guy but this is just this
is what they do the last two weeks I'm
sure this is exactly what you're talking
about now but the amount of hit jobs
that have been written on him yes pieces
from vice and Guardian and all these
other garbage these things are they're
not journalists they're activists and
they're promoting garbage nonsense and
it's kind of amazing because if you
watch him either an on Ruben report here
we did on Corollas podcast or Rogen's
podcast like it's this whole other guy
that's not being described there was I
think what really started the
conversation about him recently was that
news clip yeah that he was on the news
and this woman was trying to have a
debate with him but all of the facts
that she was you
were those snippet facts where
everything's out of context and nothing
she's saying is actually researched or
headline it's all headline and she's
like well you said this and he goes no
what I said was and there were multiple
moments where there would just be dead
silence and he'd go I got you on that
one
yeah well the beauty of it is he from
Toronto sorry yeah he's from Tehran I
remember reading about this guy and I
don't remember you should watch this I
might have bought into her head I don't
remember if I liked him or not but IRA
or he said something that he got in
trouble for and he shouldn't have I
freaked what did he say and he's a
professor at university yeah it was the
it was the trans pronoun thing was what
put him on the map because they were
gonna pass this bill or this directive
or something that if you actually use
the wrong pronouns but you might
accidentally sure all the time someone
in this room might be trans and I don't
know it you might accidentally use
guilty I was born a tall black woman I
decided no white [ __ ] that's better
for comedy that's a screwy identity
politics being right sure yeah very much
so
but yeah that's what put him on the map
but I'll tell him about you guys he
probably knows about you already but you
should get him in here I mean the guy
I'm telling you forty years his life led
up to this this isn't some guy that just
a year ago like started saying some [ __ ]
till I get people into him he's his
whole life let us trust and that moment
on UK channel four with Kathy Newman she
basically says to him she she goes what
gives your free speech why does that
supersede a trans person's right to be
offended and he just sits there and
calmly legs crossed just calmly looks at
her in smiles and he's like well you
have no problem offending me you know
him in and I like that's the truth
you're allowed to be offended of course
your as long as we have freedom left
which may not be that long is it amazing
that we've gotten to the point where
somebody a new a journalist is actually
arguing whoa the freedom to be offended
into silence you is just as if not more
valuable than freedom maybe this is why
journalists suck yes because I
journalist she would never argue as to
why she shouldn't be able to cover
something that's offensive absolutely
she would never go well you know
technically covering this is an
offensive subject so I better stay away
from it it's with my other people and
what they're saying because there's good
and bad right there's like wood that's
this is evil we're we're saying whatever
trans people want
do is yes yes yes uh so we don't need to
look into it we don't need to research
it yes because that's good and if you're
against it then you're a bad guy and
that's and that's it it's it's heroes
and villains I mean obviously you're
both right but the real beauty of this
too is it's such a great example of the
implosion of the media right now the
mainstream media simply they have been
so fat and lazy on their nonsense for so
long that now these really bright people
who have been ready to do this are
popping up out of nowhere and they don't
know how to react to them so Kathy Kathy
Newman the woman that did the interview
she basically would have to be either
the worst journalist ever or just a
complete idiot to sit down with this guy
who it's like sitting down with the
ninja and having never tried karate you
know to me in life and so they just
they're so dumb that they can't even
stop themselves so she thinks yeah that
hit that offense somehow supersedes free
speech and there's also I think that
what makes it now is that because like
we have like a show like this or like
what you do or podcast do where you can
get these guys and we're not talking to
them for 30 seconds we just found our
yeah and like really getting into what
they think and all of a sudden like
you've got this narrative that you were
hit with by every news outlet and then
you actually sit down and spend two
hours listening or watching a
conversation and hearing viewpoints
you're like wait a minute yeah it's
totally they just the clickbait article
where they have that headline of like
so-and-so said this and hates where they
make the decision for you in the
headline now you can actually get into
it but this thing they do though this
thing they do when you get them on
something well you have the right to
offend me the [ __ ] atomic bomb is
well you're not a marginalized right
right person so I suffered but that's
always their that's their go-to things
you're not marginalized so but you know
what all of these tactics they're
running out of steam because they've
done them so many times so you're a
hundred percent right so first it's that
right you're an hour you know she's a
woman so now she's the victim but then
if you watch what happened right after
so then the clip gets released
Jordan tweets it out a zillion people
tweeted out starts catching fire then
Kathy Newman and the the network all the
people at the network start tweeting all
the hate that she's getting you see
she's beaten bombard yes my faults right
hate
she's the victim right he's bullying
he's so now he's bullying her you know
he tweeted out to his people don't
attack her it's about ideas and all that
he's an alright leader and all he did
was release a clip which was technically
even her clip you online and then you
respond and you're sick you have a
public discussion if you don't want
public blowback Wow exactly but but
that's the funny thing so what they do
is so the night it comes out she's she
first sees a few responses one of her
colleagues takes a picture of her like
in the car with her phone laughing she
has a big smile on her face laughing
about all the hate she's getting oh boy
by the next day when they realized they
could spin it into now she's the victim
right now they have to release your
press release and we're gonna talk to
security and it's like yeah you do that
and you can't ever say either like
you're a journalist right could you not
check your Twitter mentions for a while
and just go back to researching things
maybe right they just suck that people
don't like your idea that's it right we
is allowed to happen you don't need to
check every Twitter mention yeah like
it's not real light trust me sometimes
it's best to lay off you know what I'm
not gonna look any at mentions that
aren't verified times we could probably
oh I mean I know how many times I can
and I'm sure yours is similar I can open
up my Twitter and just see random
anonymous pink foxes telling me to go
[ __ ] every time I open it it now seems
like when you have these arguments it
seems like no one strives to be right
they strive to be a victim yeah
everyone's trying to be like well I
think this way because like I could end
every argument with well add as a little
person as a dwarf
I've been [ __ ] now I should start our
discussion for clarity purposes as a
little person thank you guys for having
me on the show today like everyone's
striving to be that thing where now now
everyone has to feel sorry for you so
now you have an excuse to be wrong but
then they can't guess that they can't
second-guess your of your opinion
because as a marginalized person it's
like oh I'm sorry now you have ever now
you can say what
I think what a sad pathetic way of
viewing the world that is I mean they
view victimhood as virtue that's what
they think if you are a victim somehow
or if you if you are oppressed but it's
not really oppressed if you're perceived
oppressed by your immutable
characteristics the stuff that Martin
Luther King was trying to get past they
view that as as virtue and that is the
worst no one gives you anything in this
life we all came from different places
you get your [ __ ] and go but a lot of
times you know yes some people get more
and some people work harder and
everything else but it's on you but it's
easy like it's easy to go to jump there
to be like oh yeah I'm victimized and it
gives you like built-in sympathy and a
built an excuse for not doing things you
know right you know how easy it was for
us all these years Jim remember all
those easy comedy years it was easier
for Jim and me even than you
I was closeted a lot of those years yeah
Jim no because your hair really [ __ ]
you up guy with this hair everyone has
something that they can lean their head
on like hell you you can be a you you
can be a rich white male straight a
Protestant and still find something
you'd be like well we had everything so
I never knew what it was like to
struggle and that was my struggle but
like like you can reverse it all it's
also just stupid like guess what there
are people who are born into money that
are actually good people and do good
things on this world and we shouldn't
hate them for that now I'm going to go
out on the assumption that you guys one
day if you have kids that you might want
to give them something and then teach
them good things so they can go out into
the world and do good things we
shouldn't be like oh [ __ ] you see those
successful radio guys comedy guys you
see what they did they use their money
to send their kids to school
exactly it's just everything is
backwards and once you really see it and
this is why I think actually our side is
starting to win because these people
have just become hysterical our side you
mean y'all right I mean the all right
white supremacist here's the here's the
best part is it is I've been talking to
you and listening to hear you talk yeah
I don't know what your side is and right
it's the good I almost don't want to
know yeah because because then once you
say what your site is I'm gonna I'm
gonna instantly have assumptions about
you okay well he thinks this way so he
must hate these people or hate this
thing now I'm just having a conversation
with you I hate individual people that's
right guys I hate individual people you
strike me as a good guy we're good to go
yeah but I hate the idea I hate
collectivism I mean that's what I hate
that if you look at a black person and
you go all right well the I'm gonna
judge him because I judge black people
this way and that's you're saying that's
wrong I think I think your side is like
the side that most people should have
which is yeah but they've I'm on the
side of logic no and then whatever logic
is to me that's what it is and we can
have a conversation like if you we
disagree on something we can both think
that we're on the side of logic and
actually discuss it as opposed to being
like well no here's the party line
here's the rules that I follow right and
that's what I've they're gonna don't let
me know what I believe in on this issue
when they figure it yeah I I don't look
at you and be like all right you
represent the thoughts of all little
people you know it's just you know you
should king of the dwarves it was a
runoff election between me and Dinklage
he didn't show up so I got the crown can
I can I just tell one quick little
person story because I think this
illustrates the brilliance don't ask
guys has breath this involve ten
laughing frat guys
sorry that I don't say public so I had a
very good friend growing up movies who
was a little person and he actually was
a great basketball player believe me he
was a really good basketball player
used to play with him at the park on
little high school other people got on
the court
yeah but trampoline basketball no he
really was good they said I was good for
real but the funny part of he wore a
David Robinson jersey and I always
thought that was the funniest thing
because he wore a seven-foot black eye
the same thing it was a couple years we
were a couple years ago we were watching
the basketball playoffs and I had
another dwarf buddy in the room and he
was telling me what LeBron you need to
do to beat the Warriors and I just
flat-out looked at I'm like you can't
you cannot tell a six foot nine athletic
Adonis of a black man how to play
basketball right you as a four foot two
white guy cannot walk had to think as he
was 5 3 I think yeah I'm he had the
ability with that 5 4 3 right yeah
thanks and he had the ability to dribble
low and the only way to [ __ ] stop him
was the phalam is a great ball handler
so yeah not being told that being that
much shorter than anybody named yet
could be an advantage there are
advantages to it but it is more
difficult to reach the hoop which is a
yeah I would say block shots are gonna
be 100 percent so what the ones closer
to the hoop generally a better chance I
love it when I watch when I watch ESPN
and like the like the Warriors are
playing they go Steph Curry's you know
it's amazing what he does only being six
foot to like 16 like hey you know he
made it despite his height I'm like dude
realize I would do behind a dumpster to
Reuben to be 6 foot 2 okay I don't know
what kind of powers you think I have hey
[ __ ] love you're saying that we have to
break can we just go to the end and then
Brendan break and then just do the
reason we have to how many reads be I
don't have any reason that I was just
told that we have to take three breaks
alright so we don't have to break now
we'll break Dave cancer for the whole
show okay I got I got a thing okay right
but we'll break things to do we're
breaking a little bit
take your podcast I got a home studio
best thing I ever did you on these
cultures are they aren't they amazing
I flew in from Ithaca this morning I was
at five am standing on a tarmac in the
snow to get to you guys I loved at this
hour
well from Ithaca what were you doing in
Ithaca I spoke it if occur college last
night little free speech thing actually
everyone in protest wait a minute first
free speech retail in the street well
it's so cold there that even though they
threw a firebomb and it froze fire they
just stand around
no one's angry yeah it was actually
great but like you could see how these
schools have just been just crushed by
this social social justice nonsense
lighter even I literally went to the
bathroom and as I'm peeing there's a
sign in front about environmental
justice how good everything they view
everything through this twisted lens and
it's it's it's depressing unless you can
break through it but a lot of them when
you talk to them like I was doing a set
the other night I was talking about
Harvey Weinstein and gender roles on
stuff and so this woman was being a
little a little shitty in the audience
and she's like so you think those gender
roles are right like it's not even
remotely what I said I just walked her
through it
about how there was not what I said but
it's amazing how people hear what they
want to hear like that that's not
correct
close to what I was saying you can get
them I mean that's I think that's why
people are watching my show because I
though I'm being a little more forceful
with you guys cuz it's mine it's like
when I'm on my show it's a little more
measured and I do try to get people to
actually try to why do you keep thinking
these things although like then you're
like yeah yeah but but but it is
measured except the ones that get all
the buzz are the ones where you actually
have people just trying to tear each
other's throats out do you do any jokes
when you speaks on you did your stance
so I just like two weeks ago I did my
first stand-up Club gig in about five
years yeah so I was at The Comedy Store
on Saturday night I I crushed I mean I'm
not just saying it like they literally
applauded to keep me onstage I was like
I gotta go like you know I rely walked
onstage I was like listen my first club
gig in five years this is either my last
show or my comeback show and I guess at
the Commerce store in LA or the commies
did you follow Jeremy Piven
if yes is he really yes is he good or no
not that guy what you did this was this
a Dave Rubin audience or did you just
kind of guanine it out that I was going
before so I'd say it was probably like
half for me which I was shocked just
like I tweeted it like an hour before
but I just spoke to all my agents and
they're gonna start star book and some
stuff yeah it's a fun there's nothing
worse to that when the middle is killing
and you're headlining and they're like I
gotta go in the crowd goes no just the
point it's like y'all [ __ ] now they're
gonna think that I'm rushing them off
they take it out on me you know what
though it was nice because it's like I
did it for 12 years here so the tools of
stand-up I have all right you know if
you know if you're not just consistently
onstage the tools is just harder to like
get them already but like now I know
what I'm saying so you know a good comic
get out of two things you got to say
something real hopefully and true and
then you got to figure out how to be
funny it's like I'm saying something
real now that's relevant and now I just
got to get my tools sharpened and I
don't think it's gonna take that long
and I want to do like an hour special
and I don't mind being wrong either like
I just try to be honest and funny
hopefully like there's a temptation we
all want to sound smart and right but
I'm wrong half the time like everybody
else is it gives a [ __ ] you don't mind
that most of the time you're not funny
right no no except that is a platform to
really give a good but you know it's
like watching and after not being in a
club for a long time I mean it was
literally it was the first time I had
even been in the Comedy Store and it's
like after not watching stand-up for a
while man there's a lot of shitty comedy
out there like these guys they get up
there and all they can talk about is
jerking off in Trump jokes and I'm like
man you guys couldn't get within the
[ __ ] moon of truth because you're
they need it so bad I think that's the
thing that I forgot about you know that
like that just that need for every laugh
and it's like you got to get past that
and the Trump jokes are not like it's
not anything other than like again it's
it's a lot of them are clickbait
pointless jokes and I'm supposed to hate
them right I hate them there's nothing
fair about it I feel sorrow Trump jokes
and the audience liked it actually so
it's like you just got to try to hit
things from a different perspective
because the same old thing I mean it's
like turn on the daily show not that
anyone watches it anymore
things are frickin nightmare watch
Samantha bee show it's like B I'd rather
be clubbed in the head oh you were there
for you you were an intern for Jon
Stewart right yeah
way back in 99 right how long were you
there I was like 8 months I actually
forged my letter claiming that I was in
college to get the internship I was
already at a salary file I found some
letterhead from Binghamton that was
black was on - and oh yeah
yeah and he was he I mean first off John
had just taken over for Kilbourne so
John was not a star if anything he was
just some MTV guy that nobody knew who
he was
Luis black also sure you know he was can
stand up but just the yanks s really
late in life so it was an interesting
time to be there because there was a lot
of flip in terms of writers and
everything cuz well John wasn't gonna
keep the Kilbourne writers obviously try
it you literally could not have two guys
that are more different in terms of okay
a showboater and what's funny is I
remember him I didn't like him when he
was on but again I was younger than I
don't remember much about Craig I loved
him when he was on SportsCenter right
that's when I was in college so around
95 96 and I thought that guy just
totally revolutionized SportsCenter and
that's what I wanted to do was be a
sports center anchor he The Daily Show I
don't think was really his gig and
obviously John was great although I
think there's a lot of reasons that he
wasn't great inter politically I think
but at least to say that he's free he
was funny though but yeah he's a good
show and that's been a great show that's
kind of what's lost I think now is the
people's bias is stopping them from just
doing a good show like as a person who
respects content yeah you can put your
bias aside to say John Stewart it's a
good show like I don't agree with
anything this show is a good show what
is the daily show now is at arrow it's
not a good show I don't watch it I like
Trevor so much - I'm sorry to hear that
yeah it's not just watch any promo I
mean it's like the worst impression and
you're like alright we get it you don't
like Trump like this isn't comedy
anymore you know you're like you beat it
you beat the dead horse it's dead and
you're still like we can still say he
saw every single late-night host yeah
has the exact same take on politics
think about this take all the late-night
host so you got who do you got you got
Kimmel you got Alamo bear Fallon who
else who's on the guy who sings corns
for course Corden okay and and the one
that we didn't mention so far Bill Maher
if you want to kind of include
who's the most right or center out of
all of those people absolutely think how
insane that is Bill Maher has been the
standard bearer for the left especially
for comedy for 25 30 years at this point
he's now the only one that is remotely
center and if you said to Bill Maher's
face you know you're your Center he'd
punch you right not a guy goes after you
for language though he's never been a
guy who tried to get people in trouble
you have a baby no I love yeah I I love
Bill Maher - that's my point but it's so
ironic that he now is the center guy
yeah like these guys they're for your
logic yeah and you go there for free
speech I mean he's buying what a comic
is supposed to do he look he had Milo on
in the midst of all that crazy that's
right and he said I'll let you talk I
mean what did he say sunlight is the
best disinfectant if you don't like a
guy and you think he needs to be
disinfected you want to shine light on
in the street like I liked his take on
that like I don't like what he say I
mean it didn't know sighs at the moment
I feel like it did end up being really
bad for Milo's career because that is
over three days later that's what's
shined the spotlight on him and allowed
the right amount of people to be
outraged by it and exactly right like
they just destroyed him and he said to
be rebuilding ever since well that's
what every comic does to a heckler
that's like a common strategy is oh
right I'll let you talk yeah and then
you'll bury yourself right
I mean wait yeah that's how I interview
it's like I don't need to bring someone
to my studio in my home to yell at them
it's like you know Hawk and then guess
what if you don't know what you're
saying you will hang yourself and you'll
do it every time yeah and we've gotten
so used to just watching CNN and to
people in boxes or actually on CNN it's
eight people in boxes and then three
other boxes related to Trump's diet coke
habit and everything else and it's like
get past all that [ __ ] let some people
speak and that's why the Petersons stuff
that I've done I think those are my best
interviews probably because this guy has
it's not a wealth of knowledge that this
guy is this guy has like the deepest
sort of reservoir of research and
knowledge of anyone that I know of and
he's saying something real and that's
why people hate I don't know much about
him and somebody say but I'm gonna go to
the phone somebody is saying Justin in
New Jersey is to talk about Jordan
Peterson hi Justin hey guys how you
doing love the show thanks mom Sammy
bran muffins of course dogs yeah I'm
glad you guys are finally talking about
this Petersen thing
popular very very recently yeah grads
glad because of davon he he's getting
some heat this morning from Twitter some
guys taking the vice interview they went
out about him and trying to twist it so
that he looks all misogynist when he was
just pointing out that you know a lot of
women in the workplace will do things to
provoke men and that it never gets
talked about and we look we all know
you're not supposed to touch women we
all know that only the most disgusting
guys that are doing that and they're
just trying to make him look bad okay
yeah there's so what he's talking about
is thanks advice put up this thing that
they selectively edit of course what he
says and the interviewer clearly has no
understanding of Peterson and Peterson
basically is just saying you know women
wear lipstick they win Rouge when they
go to work they might put on a dress and
show some leg look I mean turn on CNN
why is every woman off the cut shoulder
Wolf Blitzer doesn't walk in there
showing his shoulders there's a reason
right that they do this and he's just
saying there there is something sexual
happening basically at all times and
that means it's happening at the
workplace he's not saying that means are
allowed to rape women or touch women
where that men can't be in rooms with
women he's just acknowledging the
flat-out simple truth that we all know
like let's have people they can't deal
with yeah why are they pigs on CNN how
can they don't have a lot of [ __ ]
300-pound women and house coats exactly
then again the men dressed not I can see
dressing nicely but they appear
intersection to it somebody named about
having the conversation right yeah it's
just about presenting this thing like
this isn't really being addressed we
could talk about this what do you think
this is but instead they frame it now
now that he hates trans people anti-aids
women you know CNN had one woman who
didn't who actually was a little older
and a little overweight monica crowley
not monica crowley kandi chronic I'm
sorry that's why because I thought she
was excellent she was probably the one
good reporter on CNN I don't know what
happened to her so I'm not saying they
got rid of her as she left but it's like
now you have all Carbon Copy 28 to 35
year old girls that all look exactly
like the Fox women grown their own fake
tan and hot and it's like well you're
proving Jordans point right get some
300-pound women on there with some real
political news let's see what when's the
last giant big fatso news person you saw
none of them not one big fat lady does
the news hey remember there's plenty of
fat guys
doing it yeah the one I'm at no but even
on you could I mean Lou Dobbs is fat oh
yeah butcher is not skinny but he's
grandfathered in from standing on there
in Baghdad when the bombs were Flay's
been grandfather did yeah he can do
anything at this point but but that's
the point
all Peterson is doing is addressing the
things we all know there is something
different about every about the sexes
that's just true it's because everything
is so cut and dry
everything is so black and white one
side of the other if you even offer any
kind of opinion that that is not the
standard and is not the flag bearing of
victimhood yeah then it's like one that
well now you're an [ __ ] but that's
why people come to us so let them keep
screaming I mean right now I'm a firm
believer he fled you Joker
Yeah right that was dark nice he's
talking about he's talking about how
quickly all of these people will just
drop their pretenses once things go to
[ __ ] and that's sort of where we're at
right now and he says something like you
just have to give them a little push
right and to me that's where we're at
with these guys we don't have to scream
we don't have to scream we don't have to
even mock them or anything it's like I
mean I will mock them but like always to
do is kind of give them a little push I
mean just look on Twitter the last
couple days the amount of people
literally calling for violence Bette
Midler tweeted something about because
of the government shutdown yeah that she
wishes the where's Rand Paul's neighbor
when you need him you know cuz Rand Paul
now I get it it's a joke but it's like
what bet me like shut up so I invited on
the show got a couple thousand retweets
I'm sure she's not going to respond but
it's like how about you come on and
explain some of this stuff all the rocks
teracle comics that we talked about last
time
explain the violence you guys are
welcome to come sit down but no no you
want to do it from Twitter yeah and you
know you all we hate borders we eight
walls and you all live in castles in LA
with security guards yeah gated
communities when Bette comes on you want
to go why don't you stop weighing in and
sing when no I don't I'm bowing out and
I [ __ ] fell apart don't worry about I
put the brakes on this fall if there's
no way to [ __ ] horn my way through
that sound like I didn't well so I have
to [ __ ] stop do you find yourself in
a conversation that you're doing on your
show specifically and I guess the ones
you're monitoring give a lot of smart
people on your show
yeah and
you'll moderate these conversations
between two very smart people yeah do
you ever find yourself like oh no
they've gone over my head oh yeah oh no
lately lost I don't know I'm Way out of
my league here this past Monday I had
Eric Weinstein and Brett assign Eric
Eric is thought of in certain circles as
literally the smartest man on earth I
mean this guy his he's a world famous
mathematician he's also the head of teal
capital this guy is real capital it's
Peter Thiel's like these and the guy is
off the chart we see my brilliant he's
got a quite a head of hair and then his
brother his brother Brett Weinstein who
you guys probably know he was the
biology professor at Evergreen State who
said that we're not going to segregate
campuses by color and then they called
him racist for it and he's a he's a
pretty world-renowned now that's Peter
Weinstein yes they're looking for Eric
Weinstein not Barbie also yeah to be
clear there he is
but these two these guys are at the top
of their fields mathematics and biology
I'm not a mathematician I'm not a
biologist and we're going back and forth
and it's like yes they drop things that
I don't fully understand and I pick my
moments when I'm like alright now you
got to slow down and we gotta reverse
some of this but but sometimes in the
course of a conversation you simply
can't do it and what I find because
people want to be smart is that my
audience then will clip out something
and then they'll repost it and then
they'll say to people this will give it
a little context and I'll link to
articles so I just am a firm believer
and that people are not morons
just put the information yeah well you
know you know when you're in someone
comes in here and you it could be a
comic that's just babbling on a million
miles a minute you can't stop them every
Tuesday now you got to kind of let it be
we get it at you're a [ __ ] okay yeah
but that's it it's like one's gonna get
by you every now and again and I've you
know I've become good friends with both
of them and I go out with them and I'm
like guys I still don't know what you're
talking about after five drinks bad
petitions what's that are they both so
Eric's a mathematician and Brett's a
biologist oh so they're going really
high level and also they're brothers so
they have their own sort of cadence when
they're speaking to each other have you
ever had someone come in with a
different opinion than you where by the
end of the interview you're like I think
I changed my mind
or at least like
a little more tolerant well I would say
on that side yeah I mean I'm pretty
tolerant in general so I don't know that
it was tolerance per se but I would say
two years ago when I was kind of waking
up to all this stuff I would bring in a
lot of libertarians and people that were
a little more right than me and the more
that I would listen to them as a liberal
I'd be like yeah this actually makes
sense like you don't want to tell anyone
how to live you want us to be treated as
individuals so that is what shifted me
I'd say Center or libertarian or right
or also known as all right neo not all
right neon uh but I've never I've truly
never heard anyone and I've had plenty
of lefties on my show I've never heard
anyone on the left say anything that
sounded to me to be right it all sounds
good but it never seems to be based in
reality or communism sounds good yeah
remember you said that but it doesn't
let them in Sami they're all hearing
that but it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense
it's not realistic yeah there's
literally millions and millions of
people who have died in the name of
right yeah yeah his way lie tell me how
socialism stood right there was that uh
there was that movie uh Trumbo with uh
with um Bryan Cranston yeah great I'm
watching that movie and Cranston is
great in it it's a great movie great
story but it was near the end of the
movie where I go holy [ __ ] these guys
are making me feel sympathy for
communism and like well they were
excluded from the Hollywood community
them like what happens where the guy who
says one thing that's labeled
conservative now he's at exactly so
unless you're James Woods do you have a
giant dick or you're Jon Voight you
won't join the Union don't realize who
can get past it okay I freaking love
James Woods now he is fearless I bumped
into him on the street like maybe six
months ago he doesn't know who I am and
I tapped him I was like James man you're
just killing it might please come on my
show sometime and basically he was like
look I can do everything I want via
Twitter if I go on your show
he's like I'm sure you're a great guy
but if I go on your show you know
they're just gonna cut you know edit it
in a way that's gonna make me look like
a crazy person he's like I got Twitter
that's all I need but I think he's even
for the stuff that I think he's a little
overboard some immigration stuff and a
couple other things it's like he just is
fearless he lives amongst them and he's
mocking them I mean that it's pretty
beautiful actually all right there are
certain guys that you should by being a
conservative oh yeah there are guys who
get it but again like I heard like
Voight and ham they're kind of so good
and they've been around for so long that
there's enough people who like I don't
give a [ __ ] I want him in this project
although James was hasn't done a lot I
mean are they still recently doing it's
john-boy yes yeah oh yeah but he's like
the one because I leaked Angelina's
father mother than John Boyd I mean
James Woods isn't doing anything you got
and would sabato Jr was it was at the
Orang season actor on those you know who
is though he's Tim Allen and look what
happened to him I made sure to show his
show got cancelled it was a top 20
sitcom that never gets cancelled and I
actually watched it a couple times and
look those sitcoms they're old and tired
sure but what was cool about it and
first off I really liked him as a comic
and I think you know you know he's the
only guy ever this is incredible he's
the only guy ever to have the number one
book number one movie and number-one
sitcom in America at the same time his
book don't stand next to a naked man the
the Santa Clause was the movie and
obviously home improvement the same week
I mean this guy's the real deal and
close to a mil a year yeah but but you
know that sitcom Last Man Standing I
watched it a couple empty wasn't great
but what was cool about it was that
every joke was the reverse of what
Hollywood gives you so the jokes were
all making fun of his son who was this
lefty environmentalism you know and it's
almost I go on the family the same type
of thing but then both of them got
attacked and and by the way all in the
family could never even be on television
you know but lazy even then they put a
warning out even in the set even in
their 70s that they had done two pilots
before the third one finally God but
they put up this is not the opinions of
the network and even back then they were
a little nervous I mean you could look
at a show that's it's a little before I
think before all of our time but mod
which was right before that I mean you
know Bea Arthur's character in that mod
I saw she was a true liberal she would
that was true liberalism not this
hysteria
yes it's craziness and that's what we
need now she played the song we're talk
about Maude I mean it really is the best
song for Maude if there's nothing better
yeah and by the way it will get stuck in
your head there's nothing that gets
stuck in your head more yeah you're all
screwed after this one I have then no
more than kars4kids
and then every now and I never have even
watched any episode of Maude but every
now and
and then there's Maude yes mom creeps
into my head and I'm piccata
Lord beside her yeah it's goddamn you
Bea Arthur but it's a great song the
interest Arthur yeah
Oh a ship on post-its were they in them
too phenomenal they both came from this
smell on the family yeah when they've
really had to do a [ __ ] Norman Lear
could do a spinoff he could do it that
[ __ ] knew how to do a spinoff
you like my hard hat no idea what if you
listen to just the words that they're
saying they're showing how women had to
fight for equality the right point
fighting for equality not for supremacy
or not for shaming everyone else by
protect quality that's what she did and
that's what we just don't have any
quality is about the the opportunity
yeah to get as much as everybody else
not getting as much as everybody else
you're not supposed to equal out the
wages you're supposed to equal at the
opportunity to get the wages I'm gonna
go out on a limb here Jim you probably
have the most money in this room what
yours you're a successful guy you
probably have the most um I'm also how
old are you 41 I'm 14 I'm 8 years old or
something my age I might I don't know
you you also have no idea how much my
pot of gold I don't know how much Sam
makes rumor has it that they do pay you
more than me so that shows you there is
something to be said for merit that
sound like a me too I don't know why why
why it why aren't the wages equal yeah
you see my point see first your initial
reaction was slightly defensive like oh
if people will think that I make money
it's a weird it's a weird thing not that
you were fully going down that route but
there's like an element of that but my
point would be that you are a successful
comic who has done good work for when
did you start comedy
1990 yeah for almost what is that 27
years yeah so about 30 years your you
deserve all that success I haven't done
it as long I don't deserve your money
that's the point we have equal
opportunity we busted our asses in
different ways we all do in our own way
and guess some of the best guys that I
knew failed and some of the worst ones
our success is its life I'll say as a
man though the reason I have a heart is
I'll never like to party I never know
how much somebody makes but I also I
have a hard time accepting anything good
as a purse as Jim Norton like I like
negative attention but when someone says
I do something well I'm like I just
panic I don't know I don't I don't we're
limited Jordan so people think that the
last professional broadcaster is broke
[Laughter]
two different colour laces and little
I've never wanted to see a house fall on
somebody pick up your game you get two
million hits god damn good [ __ ] shine
I wear these these are like these are
really good nursing home shoes I like to
[ __ ] women under 25 and I have to wear a
girl this is a bit of a shoe head with
his with his New Balance you know it's
funny I don't you know I really think
I'm gay from about 10:00 a.m. that's my
[Laughter]
fashion or just like those shoes right
[Music]
there it looks like you have a balance
problem I have Tripoli Wits the I am
very bad arches I have bad Rock ports
are comfy they look like the shoes that
they trick people into buying because
like you know you get more exercise when
you walk comfort very comfortable and I
have a hard time finding comfortable
shoes but they're awful and I know
they're off I'd love to wear Jordan just
cuz they look better and I only want to
travel with one pair of shoes cuz my
luggage is small if you want the facts
about small luggage I hate these shoes
appearance-wise and that's why i
actually believe you're straight because
if you were go through the pain of
wearing nicer shoes I certainly would
I'm gonna redefine your definition
during the break yeah you know it's one
of those things I just don't add they're
awful and I'm dressing has never been my
strong feel like today I look good but I
mean normally I know